it can't be easy for George Lucas to sit
back and watch other filmmakers guide
the Star Wars Galaxies of course it's
hard to know for sure because he doesn't
seem to say a lot on the subject lately
Lucas has not been directly involved in
the franchise since it was sold to
Disney in 2012 but he seems to approve
of the direction even if his words on
the subject are few and far between
back when the force awakens arrived
Lucas told vulture that fans are going
to love it and that it was very much the
kind of movie they've been looking for
some perceived his word choice as a
backhanded compliment but he had a
similar response to rogue one as
directed Gareth Edwards said in a press
conference that Lucas really liked the
anthology flick and just days ahead of
the release of the last Jedi to the
originator of the Star Wars universe had
a similar reaction to the flick written
and directed by Rian Johnson with his
representatives telling The Hollywood
Reporter that he thought the movie was
beautifully made and that he was
complimentary to Johnson after seeing it
Johnson had previously said that while
he was attempting to pursue his own
vision of the story he wanted it to
still be something that would satisfy
longtime fans by offering some things we
haven't seen in Star Wars before and
hopefully it still feels like a Star
Wars myth yeah that's the number one
thing but Johnson making a Star Wars
movie meant keeping it light-hearted
despite the intensity I think I hope
fans are going to be pleasantly
surprised by how fun and funny this
movie is as of now the last Jedi has a
93 percent fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes which makes it the best rated
Star Wars flick on the aggregator and
while some viewers have knocked the
movies audience score down to well below
that figure it's clear the last July has
at least offered enough suspense and
surprises to satisfy those who matter
most including George Lucas thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]